happy Friday reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch
today a trailer called long shot
starring Seth Rogen Charlize Theron I
don't know what this movie is but I like
both these actors so I figured why not
and Lionsgate loves trailer reactions so
hell yeah
listen before we hop into this guys I
just wanted to say a special thank you
to all you beautiful sons of [ __ ] and
bastards and [ __ ] and [ __ ] and pervs
and [ __ ]
to follow us on patreon yo over there we
do weekly Q&A as well as TV show
reaction stream along for many shows
that includes my hero academia I just
finished off attack on Titan Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood recently started
up one punch man Jon's covered most of
Riverdale so far he just started up the
haunting of Hell House we also cover
supernatural Wayne is gonna continue
over there and Gotham we also do
reaction highlights for a few shows with
footage included and that is for one
punch man my hero academia and
supernatural go check us out over there
he also does music video coverage that
was a mouthful let's get to this okay
Oh funny people funny people
[Laughter]
[Music]
it was like a Rob Reiner comedy it's a
pretty woman Oh
[Music]
[Music]
is Reaganite I'm sure the longshot
people yeah the long shot comes a long
trail Urkel is a long trail with two
distinct dimensions - yeah man Wow
well I'll share Jackson's in there boys
to men's in there man Andy Serkis is
playing somebody like what according to
the same with each other I didn't oh you
saw oh yeah barking oh yeah there's a
lot of famous people yeah it's kind of
feels like you know pretty woman meat
what's that one president movie that was
directed by Rob Reiner camera the name
right now I think Michael Douglas
starred in it anyway yeah I mean this
kind of feels a little bit more like the
the seth rogen comedy like 50/50 as
opposed to it's not a few good yeah this
feels a little bit more like the you
know 50/50 kind of comedy words but it
said uh less weight - it was cute
adorable
it feels charming and like it has the
potential to be kind of heartfelt the
only thing that makes me raise an
eyebrow is the random insertions of like
either hyper slapstick or like way
over-the-top like action looking
sequences like with that what looked
like a bombing or something right ahead
carrying him out and then him falling
down the stairs like onto his face those
maybe a little I just didn't know
exactly how they fit in with the trailer
stuff they were showing but a lot of
this looks pretty charming it just kind
of looks like a more tamed version of a
Seth Rogen joint yeah yeah it was if it
was less wacky and a little more
straightforward it's like a seth rogen
comedy without any of the pot yeah or
there the dick jokes
you know I feel like this could kind of
use a red band trailer this has to be
right at all right
I would imagine but I don't know that's
a good question and he's playing the
like similar position that he plays in
funny people yeah yeah exactly he's
coming in as like I'm gonna help you out
and I yeah except they're falling in
love like funny people yeah exactly and
and she's almost the president like
funny people Ike funny people choice
there and looks fine yeah I mean I'm
interested to see her in a movie like
this you know again I I don't know I
mean there's something about this I felt
a little honestly a little underwhelming
I know when Lionsgate loves it when you
say things they love honest opinions and
if you say anything slightly negative
they're like you know what to each their
own trailer you know it's alright yeah
just to tease your appetizer wait your
habits I love Charlize Theron and in a
lot of ways I feel like she's kind of
underrated even though some people might
not agree with me there I feel like she
is and I like her and I have it I can't
think of the last time I saw her and
just as straightforward comedy yeah it's
like I've seen her in movies like the
young adults which are more of the
dramedy side of the spectrum character
depth oh yeah or like jason reitman
films but something like this which is
more straightforward comedy maybe banter
based yeah yeah just like what's cool
about the Seth Rogen joins like this and
I think of movies like neighbors for
example where who's the actors from
wrote and neighbors Rose you know Rose
Byrne yeah where you just see like the
cool taking it with the actress side you
know this that side of their personality
and except here we you know she's a
high-level politician and we're gonna
see that layer to her now all I want is
for this to turn into the first purge by
the end yeah sure that's her plan the
trailer for trailer made it look like
they were hitmen oh cool yeah long shot
I get it I thought here we go
everyone's a sniper we've gotta get in
like a 90s comedy oh it's just a long
shot that they would have a relationship
I see yeah that's cute yeah which
overall there were moments where I was
like you know this could maybe be a
little better than the kind of movie
that it looks like it is but for the
most part like this looks like it might
be just enjoyable and cute at most 90s
comedy thousand percentage and I feel
like with them being without cher
Jackson saying you know you're it's
you're the pretty woman oh yeah them
saying it being aware that it's like Oh
AHA then it's called cool well yeah
thinking like we're doing this more and
more and more lately it seems because
you got like what men want you got
little and you got all these movies that
are taking other movies and clearly kind
of remaking that formula but just wig
with the gender swap or some kind of
twist and so I feel like maybe this is
the harbinger of the fact that we're
gonna get a lot more of these pretty see
yeah you know when they're getting hyper
self-aware about it
well alright this looks cute you know
who else is cute a man named Luke
Anderson so cute and he's a guy who's
been pledged to our patreon page for a
very long time and I wanted to shout him
out because he's a dude who's full of
love has his own house lives in his own
state very far away manager of FedEx and
you know it's a long shot to get this
guy to respond back to you it's been
almost four months yeah
I'm not complaining because if I don't
have to talk to you and you stay pledged
then that's like that's that's just you
know little work major reward yeah so I
hope you don't even see this shout out
that's yeah that's the best way to
maintain is don't even remember that
this patreon exists and we're all set
we're all getting what we the man with
the kind of money you make you probably
don't even notice the automatic charge
that happens on your account everything
oh yeah man you're transferring the mail
all over the world that's the most
important job all right do I believe
that because you're pledged I should
show you some TLC that I should show you
some love and attention do you think I
believe that
no no no no no love Anna tensioner for
[ __ ] I could talk so much crap on you
right now and you won't even see the
video
I mean join our patreon page wouldn't
you I don't actually know what that
means
anyhow I love Seth Rogan and I love
Charlize Theron so watch this because I
love both subscribe nation click that
notification about check some patreon
tah-dah